Die Strahlenopfer wurden wohl in ein naheliegendes
Krankenhaus gebracht und niemand dort wurde
vorgewarnt.
Vollkommen unbedacht wurde mit den Patienten
umgegangen und dabei das Pflegepersonal zusätzlich
verstrahlt.
Hier die Details bei Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich spannende Science Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal und aktiviert die Glocke..
Nur dann verpasst ihr kein Video!
Los geht‘s!
Immer mehr Details werden zu dem russischen
Atomunfall bekannt.
Jetzt meldete sich ein Arzt aus dem Gebietskrankenhaus
in Archangelsk bei Spiegel online.
Dort wurden die Opfer zunächst behandelt.
Die Umständer der Einlieferung und der Behandlung
erinnern dabei wieder an den Atomunfall in
Tschernobyl.
Hier nochmal die Begleitumstände: Explodiert
ist wohl der Flüssigtreibstoff des neuen
Marschflugkörpers SSC-X-9 Skyfall.
Er wird aber wohl zusätzlich noch atomar
angetrieben.
Bei einem Test zur Umschaltung zwischen konventionellem
und atomaren Antrieb könnte der Unfall passiert
sein.
Dabei wurden sieben Mitarbeiter getötet.
Drei der OPfer wurden in dabei in das Gebeitskrankenhaus
in Archangelsk eingeliefert bevor zwei von
ihnen an den Folgen der Strahlung starben.
Das berichtet “The Moscow Times” unter
anderem.
Niemand wusste von der Vertsrahlung und anstatt
sie zu dekontaminieren wurden die Verletzten
erstmal für Operationen vorbereitet.
Und das geschah alles vollkommen ungeschützt.
Erst auf dem Operationstisch wurde die Strahlungsbelastung
gemessen und die war so hoch, dass die Operationen
erstmal nicht gemacht worden sind.
Stattdessen wurden die OPfer erstmal gebadet.
Die Wanne soll danach so kontaminiert gewesen
sein, dass sie entsorgt werden musste.
Inzwischen hat der Inlandsgeheimdienst laut
The Moscow Times alles beschlagnahmt, was
mit dem Unfall zu tun hat und das Personal
Verschwiegenheitserklärungen unterschreiben
lassen.
Alles in allem wundert einen diese Geheimniskrämerei
und die damit verbundene Gefährdung von noch
mehr Menschen.
Insgesamt scheint der Atomunfall nur lokal
zu einer hohen Strahlenbelastung geführt
zu haben.
In Norwegen wurden lediglich eine minimal
erhöhte Strahlung gemessen.
Und auch beim medizinischen Personal wurde
nur eine geringe Belastung festgestellt.
Trotzdem löst dieser Unfall unschöne Erinnerungen
an Tschernobyl aus.
Lieber gefährdet man die eigene Bevölkerung,
als das man sie warnt und schützt und auch
im Nachhinein ist kaum etwas zu erfahren.
Wie auch beim Atomunfall in Majak 2017, über
den wir berichtet haben, wir es wohl wieder
Jahre dauern bis wirklich Gewissheit da ist,
was da in Russland passiert ist.
Hier in Deutschland wappnet man sich gerade
für einen größeren Atomunfall: Möglicher
Atomunfall: Deutschland sorgt vor & kauft
190 Millionen Jod-Tabletten Anklicken, anschauen
und bitte meine Zweitkanal Clixoom nature
abonnieren.
Da würde ich mich sehr drüber freuen!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!